an indiana educator named tony kennett
recently came on the show to speak out
against critical race theory in his
school district he exposed the fact that
counter to what officials were telling
parents racist crt was in fact being
taught to kids
we can officially tell parents we're not
teaching critical race theory it's not
in the indiana academic standards but
all of a sudden the classroom door shuts
and the teacher starts teaching through
a lens of this race essentialism that
pits students against each other based
on their color
fur saying that and for telling the
truth tony kennett may lose his job
he's been recommended for firing
following a suspension and investigation
he joins us
now was did they give you a legitimate
reason did they say you know you went on
fox and you said this or did they
cook up some bs infractions and use that
to justify it were you firing
you had to use the word legitimate
didn't you uh they cobbled together
quite a few charges that really had
nothing to do with uh of my accusations
of critical race theory at least at the
surface of course there are different
charges uh saying that i had used the
indianapolis public files for my own
personal gain that i had misquoted
district officials which of course isn't
true
and uh realistically in the meetings
though
they whined about my appearing on tucker
carlson tonight several times in every
single meeting whether it was hr whether
my supervisor yelling at me about it
everyone was horrified that i would
share publicly available emails on fox
news
so this was publicly available
information part of the curriculum you
shared it to the public it seems like
they're ashamed or they're embarrassed
because you expose the fact that they're
teaching
unpopular and subversive material to
school children is that how you assess
it
absolutely i mean we invited the indie
black lives matter activists to come
speak to a required audience of middle
schoolers in which they told the
students that and i quote crime does not
exist it is made up and that was
required for middle school students
during the day our curriculum office had
no idea about it but suddenly when we
tell the public that this stuff is going
on it's embarrassment and it doesn't
matter whether it was publicly available
information it's irrelevant and people
didn't sign up to have their emails and
their files on
in front of the public and of course
that's not true
so the superintendent who wants to nail
your hide to the wall
dr alicia johnson
uh she wants you fired she says she's
going to fire you
does she have any support
in in the community i i would assume
that you would have the support of
parents
teachers
is she just doing this on a whim because
she doesn't like you and she wants to
keep the fact that she's poisoning
children's brains secret
well there's really been a concerted
effort in indianapolis public schools to
cover up the actions of dr patricia
payne who's the director of racial
equity she runs the racial equity office
in the district
and realistically the entire upper
administration has been horrified that i
have been sharing these publicly
available documents with the public as
far as support we've been blessed to
receive a lot of parental support in the
community a lot of teachers from inside
indianapolis and some principals have
reached out and expressed their support
they don't like what's going on inside
indianapolis either and realistically
the ratio of support to criticism has
been immensely positive and we're very
thankful for that and do you have a good
lawyer
yes i have an excellent legal team
negan guard has been phenomenal in
making sure that i received uh
legal support even when indianapolis
banned me from having an attorney
we actually had to fight for 20 minutes
in an hr meeting so that i could get the
same representation rights that everyone
else has it was an embarrassment wow i
mean if we've learned one thing
throughout this pandemic is that school
administrators
some of them not all of them but some of
them could possibly be some of the worst
people
we didn't know that before but
it's becoming more clear
tony kennett good luck
you're going to need it
thanks for coming on the show
thank you merry christmas merry
christmas hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else